mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir et je souhaite que vous passiez
avec nous un très agréable moment
vous avez certainement suivi les
précédents épisodes de la série qui
retrace la vie de marie-antoinette entre
1769 et jusqu'à sa mort et bien ce soir
nous allons voir le quatrième et dernier
épisode de cette série réalisée par guy
andré lefranc et c'est geneviève casile
qui joue le rôle de marie antoinette
quels sont les rapports entre la
médecine et le sport et plus précisément
le football eh bien ce sera ce soir à
22h05 le thème de l'émission médical
d'igor barrère pierre des groupes et
étienne les loups et pour participer à
cette émission et bien nous aurons la
présence de l'équipe de football de race
cette célèbre équipe qui à part donc
prêté son concours à cette émission pour
des tests pour des études médicales et
vous venez d'entendre 7 à 23 heures que
julien mais en sens nous présentera son
journal la france en 1792 la vie et les
derniers moments de marie-antoinette
c'est ce que nous allons vivre
maintenant avec la quatrième et dernière
partie de cette série
marie antoinette
cet après midi restez donc avec nous les
missions de maurice bruzac et eve
ruggieri réalisé par jean-pierre walid
nous propose un programme très fourni
avec herbert pagani pour les variétés le
premier épisode d'un nouveau feuilleton
mauregard un aperçu du rallye auto-moto
côte d'azur côte d'ivoire une passe de
cinéma et un invité d'honneur rené
goscinny qui viendra vous parlez de son
héros lucky luke
nous allons retrouver dans quelques
instants une minute pour les femmes les
missions des lianes victor mais
auparavant j'aimerais vous rappeler nos
principaux rendez vous de la soirée
tout d'abord à 19h45 nous pourrons
suivre le dixième épisode du feuilleton
de jean-pierre richard iii de coeur à
20h30 nous irons au théâtre pour voir
une comédie en noir et blanc de gabri à
la roue déjà diffusée le 4 juin 1970 et
intitulé deux fois deux fonds 5 et les
quatre acteurs que nous retrouverons
seront alain pralon michel grellier
michel roux et colette castel puis après
la dernière édition de tf1 actualité
c'est à dire à 22h45
nous irons à montréal pour assister en
direct à diverses épreuves des jeux
olympiques mais pour le moment je cède
la place à anne marie peysson
puisque nous allons passer cette soirée
ensemble autant la rendre très agréable
et pour commencer de la musique avec un
concert donné par l'orchestré
philharmonique de berlin sous la
direction de robert von karajan alexis
weissenberg va interpréter ce soir le
concerto numéro 2 pour piano en ut
mineur de rachmaninov
puis à partir de 21h10 notez-bien 21h10
georges arnaud et georges ferraro vous
proposeront une grande enquête sur la
sphère moon une enquête qu'ils ont mené
aux quatre coins du monde à bord aux
états unis où vit fastueusement celui
que l'on appelle le révérend moon puis
en corée du sud où est né le monisme en
france et au japon il a essaimé de
nouveaux éléments de réponses arriveront
peut-être à éclaircir cette affaire
23h15 on vient de vous dire ce sera
l'heure de la toute dernière actualité
présenté et commenté par bernard à la
soirée commence place à la musique avec
je vous le rappelle ce concert donné par
l'orchestré philharmonique de berlin
sous la direction d'hervé rvn karajan
vous l'avez vu vous mêmes nous avons
quelques petits ennuis techniques harris
dommage alors le temps de réparer tout
ça et vous allez pouvoir voir la belle
aventure alors vous nous excuser s'il
vous plaît et dans quelques instants
la suite du programme merci